douie welcome to the Pod thanks for
having me man thanks for having me and
it's doy doggy dougy doie I think yeah
obviously I told you we say about this
in my team they were like convinced it
was doggy but I was like no it's doggy
you should really own that I know I need
to make a decision on it right I think
it's just speaking to people in England
or not in Scotland it's always douy it's
like they understand that easier than
duy but I appreciate it so we wanted to
make some time to have a chat yeah about
a few things we've done quite a bit of
work together this year with the podcast
and and sourcewell so definitely want to
talk about that we've done three live
podcast events this year which have been
super fun and then we've also work
together on the BD Playbook series which
went down really well absolutely and I
think we wanted to also just talk a bit
about definitely like your journey I
think you've been on such a great
journey considering I saying we sat down
in
2019 uh when I worked for hwo so that
was insane that was London a little Rim
up up a set of stairs right at the back
yeah so we sat down when you was at odro
in 2019 and then now you've been on this
journey with s in the last two years so
definitely want to just touch on that CU
I think there's definitely things there
that people can learn from and then also
like yeah really interested to dig into
like your perspective sitting in the
seat that you're in on like how Source
has been helping a lot of the companies
and customers that you've been
partnering with this year cuz I I do
really feel like you guys have been at
the Forefront of driving just Better
Business Development habits and just
better like practices across the
industry um and then I think we want to
talk a bit about the future and some of
the the really cool features that you
guys have rolled out this year so how
how have you found the events this year
honestly man I think the events have
been sick like if I look back at um the
first one of the year was in Manchester
right we did Manchester first and I
think that was probably my favorite
event of of the year just having
everybody together in one room um
everyone was just so like the panelists
as well so I think you had Alex Kyle and
Amber and they were just so open about
you know the challenges cuz that was
like what April May time yeah so we were
in the the midst of Market was really
starting to slow down BD was really the
focus people were starting to change
their approach and I think all three of
them delivered like really actionable
insights in terms of stuff that could be
done to to improve and don't get me
wrong the London and Bristol events were
amazing as well but I think like the
real value from the events has being
people actually sharing tactical advice
and not just big massive thoughts and
ideas that sound great but don't
actually translate to to Really some
really good tangibles from that episode
I think what what I remember from stuff
like that is just like always Manchester
it doesn't quite go to plan yeah nor
than as alcohol it's always a bit of a
mess I'm sorry it wasn't anything too
crazy but I just all I remember stuff
like that definitely like yeah they did
such a good job of communicating like
the things that are working for them the
things that they're doing thing but I
just remember getting down into the room
where we did the podcast and then people
were like just still trying to get a
drink and then everyone was waiting yeah
and then you remember the mic as well
you had to do that was a bit of a so
they're the sort of things that I
remember from those types of things
totally but that's the thing you must be
under pressure right to deliver like you
feel the pressure of delivering a really
great event and then these little things
are starting to like that are like
outside of the pan so your head's almost
on that versus the versus the stuff no I
agree that that was that was great I
think it's something shared with you but
I do think if you think of those three
uh people Alex is very much involved in
a business that recruits in the tech uh
SAS space yeah Kyle that's his space as
well and then because I've got to know
Amber I know that she consumes a lot of
content from B2B SAS uh go to
market uh content and I've definitely
found like when we think about you know
what you guys are doing multi Channel
approach that's like
just expected or been so normalized for
a long time from my understanding in
those types of spaces absolutely so I
think I shared with you that people that
tend to operate in that space often
times are sort of probably quite a few
steps ahead of you know a bunch of other
people in the industry because they're
they're they're placing or dealing with
people that already approaching sales
the way that they're approaching it
right yeah so they obviously have
exposure because naturally through the
questioning that they do on like
candidate interviews or Cent me like
they're learning about these um skills
and techniques and processes like you
said because ultimately they're placing
people into those jobs like don't me
wrong I I definitely still think there
is Nuance to recruitment that is not
applicable always within the sales space
right but I do think that if we're
honest a lot of what we do as recruiters
as sales we've got a kind of B2B sales
process which is you know the selling to
the client if that makes sense and then
we've got a kind of b2c sales process
which is like this the sale with the
candidate um or you know potentially
selling them on an opportunity um so I
think what a lot of those people have
done is they've identified like the
transferable processes and approaches
and they've been able to then apply that
to to the recruitment space but I do
think you you need to be really aware of
like you said those new or like we said
there those nuances and those changes
because if you just hold took everything
that was happening SAS and applied it to
recruitment you'd yeah probably end up
with a pretty ineffective business model
and and and not a lot of placements at
the end for sure but like you've been as
I was saying like you've been I think
you've been on such an interesting
Journey so like years of AO where you
literally was like one of the earlier
employees right absolutely working with
with Ryan and then by the time you left
you were cro of that business but you
had also got exposed to like customer
success sales other things I'm sure and
then for the last two years you've been
in the seat of cro for SAA right like
what I'm just curious cuz you've been
serving this rect Tech market for quite
a while right nearly nearly a decade so
how how much with when you see yeah so
like how how much have you seen it
change like if you think of like the
landscape now uh and the types of
products available for growing
recruitment companies like how do you
see it from like your see cuz you've you
would have come up against a lot of
companies when you worked at orro you
would have been aware of the different
partners likewise now sourcewell yeah
absolutely the the market has a decade
sounds wild um but the market has
changed Market's changed a lot
particularly from like the technology
that's available to people I remember
back in 2016 when I first joined audro
and and you know I was working with Ryan
and we were trying to kind of get the
message out there and stuff you know
this this concept of even meeting people
online was super alien never mind
recording that interaction right it's
like this concept you would even record
you would even meet people online and
then record it whereas I can't remember
the last time I was on an online meeting
where it wasn't automatically recorded
whether that's internally or externally
predominantly externally and um you know
I think you know back then that was
almost quite I would say revolutionary
but definitely a very new idea and A New
Concept I think a lot of the tech that
existed back kind of 2016 2017 were a
lot of it was still to do with was
coming more so from like the like the
in-house side of things so a lot of like
jobboard technology search and match you
know a lot of that kind of candidate
work where is what I see a lot more now
in the market is tools that Focus also
on the business development side of
things and but a big focus on recruiter
efficiency and automation as well so but
I think like automation AI efficiency or
an approach to a more efficient process
is something that's become more of a
focus for recruitment businesses
naturally over time um I don't
necessarily think that back in 2016 many
people were thinking they are the way
they are now which is how can we do more
with less which I think is probably the
main focus for most most businesses do
you think I speak to somethingone about
this today yeah do you
think recruiters are more efficient now
with all these tools available compared
to when they didn't have all these tools
available cuz the person I was speaking
to was pretty convinced that they're not
you know man it's it's going to be weird
for someone in my seat to say this um I
think like right now as it stands right
now um probably not um and I think it's
because of the volume of tools so we've
gone from if you think of this like
small circle of of um of like additional
products on top of your CRM that you
could purchase to now there are like
multiple products within multiple
segments um you know avail that that
didn't even exist as like a product
category before and very few platforms
and products are doing what other
platforms and products are doing as well
so for example if I wanted to achieve
this end goal of having everything in my
process automated and this analytics set
up and whatever it might be I'd have my
CRM and then maybe five six seven
different you know pieces of Technology
bundled onto that there's no way that
anyone can effectively use you know five
six different pieces of Technology on a
day-to-day uh in their in their role I
think probably what we see more so is
there'll be recruiters who gravitate
more so towards the products that do
make them more efficient but then they
cap out on that so
um no I don't think recruits are more
efficient right now I think they can be
but I think it's going to take something
or somebody to kind of almost um pull
all of those platforms together into one
place that allows people to execute that
rather than having them working across
five six seven different yeah so what
what excited you about sourcewell then
when you started to cuz I'm sure you
would have had other offers
opportunities yeah it was really
interesting so for me there was three
main things um the first one was the the
team um and this isn't you know I'm not
comparing this to what I had at odro
this was more so just looking at this
from like a like through a very
different lens in terms of like what am
I going to do next um so you know Tim
and Harry are both you know incredibly
intelligent people um both don't come
from a recruitment background so I found
that really interesting um but both very
very well educated and and and have
backgrounds in different Arenas and they
built this kind of inial team who um
really driven really motivated um and
really you know really believed in what
they were doing so that really stood out
to me second thing was the product um
and the product was the part that
captured my attention because I knew of
source wh and I'd spoken to Ben who's a
VP of our VP of sales now um and Tim a
number of times over probably a 12 month
period before I before I joined um
Source whe and the product always stood
out to me in terms of the way it was
just taking something that was such an
obvious problem and making it so much
more simple for everyone like you know
at its core automating follow-ups you
know just that's it like you know if I
can just automate the follow-ups that I
need to send then you know never mind
all the other bills and whistles that in
itself was super valuable and and then
the third thing was their passion for
the US market so I was really Keen to
you know looking at what I want to do
the next is like take things more
internationally we've done a lot of work
at Udo in um in the UK um and in like
places like Asia and some work in the US
but we'd never really had boots in the
ground um so for me I wanted the ability
to kind of do more in the US market and
I mean so far so good it's not it's not
been without its challenges but we're
definitely making head Headway there and
then like I always ask you this this
right but like how how have you managed
juggling all this with a young family
mate like you're saying you fly flew
down this morning yeah you know I always
all when I think of people uh it's funny
when I think of Scottish people in
recruitment I think of you Nick who else
do I think of guy that works at page now
I can't remember his name Cammy Cammy
yeah and like you know I feel like did
you work at Udo or not yeah Cammy at
yeah so like and I think how are these
guys just getting on the plane every day
on the easy jet or Ryan whatever coming
down honestly there's a thing called the
EasyJet postcard right and it's say
you've got to get an easy jet Plus Card
basically gives you fast track security
it gives you H you get on the plane
first and you get extra leg room and
it's like it's like 150 qu a year or
whatever but it's just it's it's
absolute godsent um but like honestly
like from a family perspective I'm
really lucky like my wife's fantastic
you know she's great um it is hard
though like I wouldn't say I wouldn't
say it's easy to just always be like you
know away from the kids my daughter
she's eight now my son he's 18 months
old I mean just the age Gap alone
between those two is an intense an
intense thing um and it's great you know
absolutely love spending time with them
um but I I think that doing business
face to face is both internally and
externally just gives you a kind of an
advantage over so many people in the
market and so many other people in the
industry so I I would never be able to
give that up you know ultimately it's my
choice to work with an organization that
is headquartered in London that has
operations in the US and when I was at
audro you know W it was headquartered in
Glasgow predominantly served businesses
that were based in London and you know
that's part and parcel of the job and I
got all of the upsides of that as well
right I got all of the benefits of of
what that brings so yeah sometimes you
got make some sa I just always respect
it so so talk to me about let's like
reflect a bit on 2023 cuz I think
think one of the the core overarching
themes of all the conversations I've had
this year obviously I'm speaking to
companies about how they can get more
out of their people yeah what skill gaps
do they have and and the most common one
has all like throughout this entire year
has been last year was very job heavy
and I think a lot of people went into
this year not equipped with the right
skills to thrive in what's been you know
a lot more of challenging Market
compared to what people have been used
to I think a lot of people that have
been in the industry for a long time
would just describe it as a a
competitive good quality Market where
you have to work hard and uh you can
absolutely still thrive in the market
like it is today but I think a lot of
people didn't have those client
acquisition skills which I
think a lot of people struggled with and
obviously that that's why I really
gravitated towards source and why I
think like you said it's such an obvious
problem yeah cuz when I think about when
I worked in Recruitment and I think
about how I used to do business
development it it was every Tuesday and
Thursday 10 till 12 I knew that it was
the BD time obviously got to be doing BD
out that as well but we'll be doing it
we'll be doing it collectively and I
would be just chasing uh live vacancies
I would be looking at my calendar and
seeing who did I call last week and it
was just like so manual and so rying on
my own brain to remember like what I
need to be doing there's no
strategy so I know you guys do so much
more than this but like that's why I
think in terms of like the the pro one
of the problems that you solve for a lot
for a lot of your companies I just feel
like you guys are front and center of
like what people have had to do or how
they've had to adapt this year so talk
talk to me a bit about like what have
been from your perspective some of the
like one two biggest problems that
you've been partnering customers to to
solve for them absolutely I think just
before we go into that it's worth noting
that actually some of the the biggest
success and the biggest traction that
Source wheel had gotten um you know
prior to me joining was actually in the
was actually in candidate sourcing
really so yeah so like what happened
obviously the because this concept of
like automating follow-ups applies not
just to clients it applies to candidates
as well so in that market where it was
really job heavy and everyone was trying
their best to engage with candidates you
know the best way to do that was to not
be the guy or girl that gave up after
the first
you know they were getting a lot of
emails but if you were the person that
was emailing them two or three times and
then dropping a phone call in and then
maybe messaging them on LinkedIn you
stood more of a chance of having that
having that conversation um and what's
happened
is by working you know with the
customers that we've had we've been able
to kind of support them from that
transition from the candidate source and
you know a lot of their work being spent
on candidate source and more so towards
that business development model as well
um I think like for me the main part is
like that that Automation and
organization piece so been able to um
organize everything that a recruiter is
doing from a BD and head hunting
perspective into one place so their
calls or emails or LinkedIn messages and
automating some of that for them but
still maintaining a strong element of
personalization and but then just making
sure that they know how to reach out to
and when and when you've got a bunch of
people who are learning how to probably
even do BD for like the first time not
having to remember that part of the job
and actually just focusing on what they
have to say when they have the
conversation or when they're writing
that email just makes life a whole lot
easier for them as well and what have
you found when you've had your
conversations with the sales team and
these things like what is the most
common way you found that people do do
that before sour I youget what I mean
like are you is it still very much like
people using their email calendars
they're set themselves reminders like
how are people typically doing it it's
really varied um there are people who
have like I mean I still use a day plan
if that makes sense but not for that
type of activity I set down and I you
know I see what this is the meetings I
want to have today Etc and but there's a
lot of people who still track down and
say Here's the call back I'm going to do
tomorrow morning and they'll write that
down their notepad um email calendars I
think some CRM systems have like a
reminder system so like you know set a
Remer to reach out to this person on
this date or whatever um but none of
that is obviously linked into what
happens before it so if you'd responded
to me or whatever it might be obviously
don't want that reminder to then come
through because it's no longer relevant
um and then there's some people who use
spreadsheets so they'll actually pull
out and these are the people who are
actually Clos us to think to doing what
source whe achieves from a technology
perspective but manually where they'll
plot out on a spreadsheet on the top
like step one to step eight and what
each of them are and then every time
they do it they'll put like a little
Cross or they'll color the box or
whatever and go through it so obviously
not the most efficient way but like they
still yeah I think why I think that's
great CU I think this is part of the
problem that you guys are trying to help
solve is a lot of people don't have a
system yeah towards their business
development or the the the head hunting
they just know I'm going to keep trying
until I maybe get a rejection or I get a
no do you know what I mean I mean
there's no like I I can't put my bed
plan into like a system I think that's
also where I think sometime people
really need to think about that as well
yeah and I think that's you're talking
about the biggest problems that's that's
the second problem if I think of it like
from like a management or leadership
level whether you've got people who had
experienced at Business Development or
are doing it for the first time or or
anybody on that Spectrum it's really
hard to actually get an Insight in terms
of like what's working you know um you
know is our messaging resonating are are
we making enough calls um are the calls
that we're making actually leading to
results um is the way that we approach
candidates in this space different the
way we approach candidates in that that
space because
ultimately it's you know it's hard to
see a kind of a single view of that data
and you're always relying on the
recruiter manually logging that
information in the CRM to even get you
anywhere close to that in the first
place so been able to give that data and
insight automatically to the management
team and also then automatically track
it into the CRM for the recruiters means
that they save time the recruitment side
but the management team gets the data
that they need and and everybody w I
think that's the beauty of it yeah
that's that's what I really that's what
I also gravitated towards as well
because like if I was to log into my
source well now dunor in the sales team
like she she's got like an unreal open
rate and then when I've been doing some
of my campaigns recently I've been
getting know in what she's got I'm like
but I can see what yeah exactly but I
can like I can see the emails that she
done what's working so that's what I
also liked as well cuz if I think back
when I was in recruitment like every is
sort of almost working in their own
silos so if like someone's got an
unbelievable inm response rate and I
could there could be a good chance I
have no idea what they're putting in
that and they may not even want to Sho
it with you I remember I remember I
think I told you this story but um my
one of my first ever recruitment jobs
there was a guy who was great at selling
retainers like we would go into the
month and this guy had already done his
his Target or quarter for the month
sometimes he would come into a quarter
and he'd already done it it was wild
right it was UN un believably good I
mean he works in the Cayman Islands now
like doing like private aate Recruitment
and stuff I mean he's amazing right he's
really really good um but I remember
asking him I was like oh like like teach
me you know how do you do that was like
19 or something and he was like I just
make it happen I that's just so not
helpful like you know how and and you
know still to this day has never taught
me how how he did it but I think um you
know it is especially when people are
working remotely and working from home
like that was a conversation I could
have with him in that office and if he'd
been more inclined to do so he could
have give me some guidance or advice um
but you're right like you just don't
always have that that ability to have
that conversation and even if you do
there's no there's no guarantee that you
would if you think about ramping up the
performance of my people more quickly
rather than dogie joining my business
trying to have to figure out for however
a long period like what's working what
isn't I can just equip you with some of
the best Outreach messages that are
working right now for the team totally
do you know what I mean it's just simple
stuff like that what um what I was going
to uh say was we're talking about being
aici
like how how important is it like to
really maximize partnering with you guys
is it going to be a real ball Lake if
like like how so basically if I have a
CRM am I really going to get the most
out of sourcewell if sourcewell works
with that CRM do you know what I mean
cuz we're thinking about being efficient
cuz like how how effective are you guys
going to be if I've got a CRM but then I
have to you know log into do you know
what I mean just sharing that because I
think that's important to get people's
yeah it's a great question so we
integrate with over 60 different systems
um so you know if you think of like the
most common you know recruitment CRM
systems like we probably already
integrate with them um
so ultimately the whole point of of
source whe the way that we see Source
wheel in the future for the business and
for for the the platform is we see
source as your system of work you see
your CRM or your ATS system as your
system of record and essentially if
you're having to execute any of your
business development or candidate
sourcing activity that's all executed
from a single place inside source wheel
and we'll aut automatically log all of
that information for the system record
so you don't have to like get to Friday
afternoon and be like tapping away and
saying I these calls or that calls it's
all it's all just going through okay
yeah that makes sense so talk to me
about what have been some of your you
can even talk from like personal like
what you think have been great or just
the stuff that you know that you here
for customer success but I've written
down some of the features that we've
really enjoyed using this year but what
have been some of the the best features
you think that people really enjoyed
using this where um using this year at
sourcewell absolutely I think there's
probably
three three that's spring to mind um I
think the first one which
was really a bit of a game changer
around May time um in the June again or
sorry end of May was um content coach so
again everyone's trying to do business
development everyone's out there there's
more email content LinkedIn Ming Etc
than ever before so what we did was we
took um data from over 21 .8 million
pieces of Outreach that had gone out
through the platform we looked for
Trends and patterns of things that were
working best um and we then created um
almost like an algorithm and system in
the background that when you're now
writing a message inside source wheel or
an email or whatever it might be we
score it against that framework and then
provide insights directly to the user so
we we can let you know if there's
particular spam phrases that you're
using or if the subject line is too long
too short um or you know if there's
certain phrases or techniques or calls
to action that you should May that
they're using as well um and that's been
that's been massive in terms of the
Improvement that we've seen from what
the average kind of content coach score
was pre-launch to like post launch and
seen over that time yeah cuz that was
the one I put down the I put it as email
score is what's it called content
content coach there we go do better
marketing on the name of it content
coach that makes sense yeah no that that
is so helpful yeah because you know how
there's so much information out there
now as well yeah but I think you know
you're not and I always say this to
people that do
uh considering source using it like a
big part of it is also you know knowing
how to write an effective message
absolutely because you can be doing like
let's be honest like we we promote
obviously multiple steps multiple
channels But ultimately If the message
isn't great then you're not going to get
results like you can send it 100 times
but it's just not going to you're not
going to if you can help me understand
where I can improve and that that's the
same like I've I've used uh grammarly
for like oh for so long and I think if I
think about when I first started using
to now like my writing has become so
much more concise and you just get
better so the idea would be hopefully
when you you know write out these
initial messages your your Baseline is a
much higher score which means there's a
more likelihood you're getting response
open ratees these things that's it I
think him just on grammarly my I'm
convinced that my spelling grammar and
punctuation is worse than it's ever been
because grammarly like just corrects it
all for me and I'm not even aware of it
anymore so I just like type things out
and I don't even know if they're but
like I'm so I'm so grateful for it
because it's not something that I've
ever you know know had a massive kind of
you know focus on so actually having
that there automatically correcting that
is is absolutely beautiful so what else
jumps out so I've got on here uh I'll be
honest I haven't probably played around
with the uh well GPT I'll be honest so
the ones I put down were insights that
that we really enjoyed that cuz
obviously you know when you're looking
at people that you're sending messages
to you're looking for any you know
points that you can use for
personalization and that made that so
much easier being able to sort of see
that in one window absolutely and I
think we talk about the power of
personalization because I think like
we've used the words automated and
Outreach and sequences and people you
know might have this view where you just
sit and blast out four or five emails
you press a button and everyone just
gets the same content but obviously
that's not the power of source wheel
right like the power of source wheel is
having that kind of facility but with
the personalization um added in and like
you said insights is essentially this
feature whereby if I'm on your LinkedIn
profile for example it gives me
information such as like an overview of
your company so when it was founded um
you know kind of Revenue employee head
count um gives me a l of competitors
potentially so if we're thinking of um
an organization targeting a tech company
they can start to see okay well if this
is a company that I want to try and win
from then I might want to try and
approach these organizations as well um
and then obviously get things like news
any job postings that they've got on
which is obviously valuable and then
funding as as well yeah so like we found
that really uh helpful but you are you
are right I think for most of our
campaigns the first thing that we have
in there is a custom variable which we
have to fill out yeah but then we've
sort of scripted and templated and
played around with then like the core
message but yeah if you're just spending
time on the personalization element and
hopefully giving yourself a better
chance of it being opened and responded
to but then the the other elements are
automated then that's I think the I
think the beauty of it as well is like
it makes the calls warmer so you know
knowing that that first Emo's going out
with that personalization maybe there's
a second email that goes out as like an
automated followup but then the third
step is you know hey hashm you've got
you know 14 phone calls to make today
click here to log in and make them um
and then you know you can see the
previous content that's gone out you've
got that information I'm going to call
you up I can reference the content that
I've already sent to you as well
anything else jump out to you I put how
long have you had the live feed on there
H it's not live yet
not that got me excited cuz it's going
to be sick we've been playing around
with it internally like again you know
cuz that's like I think of spot on that
like the hub spot extension cuz it's
really helpful to see when someone opens
an email or like what's going on CU then
you can be a bit more reactive sometimes
you can get on it Street we and again
we're talking about like BD in 2024
we'll maybe come on to this later um you
know getting in touch with people when
the intent at the highest is is
obviously the IG element absolutely we
used to do that at audro a lot where you
know when we would send people like
video messages and we would get
notifications when it was watched and we
would you know make a point of calling
people um instantly and they would be
like that's so weird I'm watching your
video and I'm like I know like that's
part of the product and it be a great
way to is anything else that you've
enjoyed or you know that people have
enjoyed there's been there's been Lots
man I think um I think we do a ton of
upgrades and um and updates to the
Integrations that we work with that just
that aren't like super sexy for the
front end but you know are always there
to support the way because everybody
someone might have a certain CRM but
actually every recruiter tends to use
their CRM in a slightly different way so
we do a lot of custom work that that
helps people feed information in the
background what we what we saying about
going into next year then so like I just
put here like features we're we're
excited about what are things that are
front of Mind top of mind that you know
people are probably going to be excited
about yeah I think um I try not to
commit massively to to major road map
updates but um I touched on it a little
bit earlier we've very much get this
vision of system of work right so we see
Source b as being you know our our
mission is very much to look at the
entire end to-end recruitment process
and look for where friction exists and
then work to remove that friction which
is what we've done with our core product
on the business development head hunting
side um our candidate Source inside so
we're looking at a couple of things into
the new year um in terms of you know
when you're making calls through the
platform how can we make that easier for
you how can you maybe make that natively
through our platform rather than having
to use you know third party systems that
you plug in um you know subsequently
from that how can we make sure that
we're then taking summaries of those
calls and putting them back into the CRM
system for you that be um and then
there's a couple of other things that
we're looking at around like the you
know once you get that meeting with a
client or candidate and you're having
those meetings how can we provide
Insight on what happens in those
meetings to your leadership team to
coach you um and even down to things
like you know if automating the followup
has always been our key what happens
when you submit a CV to someone how do
you make sure that there followups to
get those interviews book in in place as
well and it's not just following up when
you're trying to get the meetting But
actually following up when you're when
you're in the process so there're just a
couple of things that are top of mind at
the moment there's obviously a ton more
on the road map but yeah I'm really
excited for it man yeah I do really like
that idea of like your system for work I
think that's a good way to think about
it totally um yeah get your point on the
the phone bit cuz that makes sense cuz
when you do it right now you have to use
whatever phone product you're using yeah
absolutely and that's the thing we'll
never look to you know if you've got a
third party perform system that you love
and you're then cool like we obviously
have that integration where you can call
through the platform and and they work
together but there are people who don't
have that set up and you know they're
calling for their mobile Etc that
information is not recorded it's not
logged into their system so rather than
just saying a call was made we want to
be able to say a call was made here's
the recording of it and by the here's a
summary of what happened in that
conversation as well and push that into
the push that into the system so what
like to round round like look round out
looking ahead like from your perspective
obviously you're in an interesting seat
like what do you think you know great
companies are going to be doubling down
on going into next year when we think
about this multi Channel approach
because for me for a lot of
conversations that I'm having with
people it really is about how can we
make sure our our team have the right
skills and the right right tools to
really
maximize uh the market when there will
be another uplift but let's learn from
this year make sure that you know when
things do pick up when maybe people are
saying more yes there's more maybe
funding released in certain areas when
it's just a bit more buoyant our team
could really maximize that um whilst
also making sure that you know things do
continue to be difficult or more
difficult than they have been that
they've got the right skills and tools
so like what are you saying people
really what do you think people should
be down on ah it's an interesting one
right like I think if I was to look at
it selfishly from a source wheel
perspective
um you know obviously the platform like
from our side we always we're
consistently pushing the message of it's
great that you know that you're all in
on BD at the moment but how are you
doing your candidate Source in the
background you know can we make sure
that Source whe is you know executing
that for you as well I think um a big
part of the move for 2024 internally
will be people continuing to coach and
upscale their team not just on their BD
approach but also and their pitching
ability making sure that we don't end up
in this almost reverse bubble where the
market flips back to candidate sourcing
and people have forgotten how to engage
candidates properly right like it's
almost this like weird this weird Matrix
but I think the big one will actually be
offline events um I see yeah like I just
think like off offline connection like
in a market where everyone is trying
their best to engage with people and
trying to stand out is there anything
better than being able to actually meet
someone face to face whether that's at a
live podcast event or whether that's for
dinner or for coffee or you know an
exclusive Round Table event or whatever
it might be we've seen massive traction
this year by you know meeting people
offline and certainly from what we're
hearing from the clients that we work
with like some of the more kind
of I was going to say successful ones
but certainly the ones who are reporting
that they're you know not finding it as
tough as the others as they've doubled
down on making sure that their business
development approach isn't just to
Simply get a Mee and to win a job yeah
it's to it's to you know create an
offline relationship and so I think I'll
be it's interesting to say that right CU
it's
like it's almost like we got
go so far one way where like cuz I I do
agree with you what we've really been
trying to do this quarter is see as many
of our clients face to face as possible
yeah which is involved a 2-hour drive
out of London these types of things and
it's almost like it's so easy to not do
that now and it's so easy to use chat
GPT to create my email Outreach that if
I sort of overdo it on that people see
through that and it's all then like not
doing too much of that or going the
other way that people then really
appreciate do you know what I mean and
like that's the thing like I think it's
always going to be like trying and do
what most people are not doing is almost
the is almost the I've seen like post on
like don't use like AI for this don't
use a for that and then do you know what
I mean it's of most we try and like
really evolve things in a certain way
and then it's like what would help you
actually Stand Out is we had a we we had
a kpi audro which was the number of like
on-site client visits or onsite
trainings yeah so we used the KP our
team um on it was a minimum of four a
month so you had to go out there you had
to meet with either a client face to
face or or a customer face to face and
that's where a lot of the training we
did in fact actually for a very long
time up until the pandemic even though
we were a video technology company we
insisted on trading people at their
offices I remember when we rolled out
Austin Fraser when I was at audro which
was a couple months after actually we
did our 2019 podcast um I traveled to
their London and ren offices and then I
did Munich Berlin and Hamburg and then I
did Austin Dallas and Denver to launch
the product and you know the engagement
that we got in the back of that was you
know much better than what it would have
been if we just simply had you know all
of those Consultants there was I can't
remember the exact number it was over
100 of them just on on uh
online yeah it's interesting that is
it's definitely like I can definitely
Echo I think yeah a lot of recruitment
companies have that or should have that
as part of their strategy how are
they're going to bring people in that
industry together what they're doing is
it through podcast is it through you
know Network working events is it
through round tables whatever it may be
uh so that that makes sense do you want
to quickly Enlighten us when we're
thinking ahead yes these uh what a lot
of people been posting about these
deliverability rules you want to just
give us some wisdom on that mate
absolutely um so the the deliverability
rules really apply to like Google and
Yahoo workspaces um essentially um it
was a few weeks ago now they came out
and said look from kind of February uh
2024 if you are sending uh more than
5,000 emails and 0.3% of those are
marked or reported to spam which I think
is 15 then there's going to be a massive
clamp down on your domain essentially um
what was really interesting about this
at the time was that didn't just apply
to like marketing emails that you were
sending from like your CRM system with a
massive mail shot or the emails that
you're sending for BD either from your
own emails or through something like
Source whe and although Source whe does
use your emails um or actually even like
me and you right now organizing to meet
up today right so like all of those
types of emails were all included in
that in that 5,000 number so naturally
that freaked people a little bit because
look you can start to calculate how
quick and easy it would be to go above
that number in a slightly larger
organization and the part that was that
was really tough on it was that it was
applicable not just to personal like at
gmail.com so candidates essentially but
also workspaces as well really hard to
know who's on a Google
workspace but actually over the last
couple of days what's happened is Google
have actually updated that guidance to
say we stand by what we were saying
previously however it's applic not now
to Gmail workspace but only to to
personal email addresses however you
know really Keen to say that that could
change again like actually if you go
into their FAQs on it right now and you
refresh it a couple of times it goes
from saying that it doesn't include work
to it does include work so I think
they're probably I think they released
that saw a significant amount of
pressure obviously from from their
customers and then have maybe made some
some changes I don't know but I think
like ultimately there are some things
that you can do to avoid fall and F to
that anyway but I think it's important
to be of what those those changes are
yeah I mean regardless like if it
encourages people to think about the
quality of what they're sending and how
much and like how relevant it is who
it's for I only think that's a net net
positive you're spot on and you were
talking about like the changes that
people are going to make in 2024 yes
getting people offline is obviously
important to build that relationship but
just making sure that you're breaking
down your ICP segment and not just
saying hey we've got a tech candidate
update let's send it to any candidate
that works in Tech on our database
actually saying here's an update for
developers versus CTO versus XY and z
and then being really specific with that
approach um you know that's talking
about it from a markeet marketing
perspective and then yeah from a sales
perspective like you know reaching out
to people one-onone just take the extra
time to personalize something like I
don't get people who just want to plug
something in and then just blast it off
and then think oh well we might get five
or six responses from it like it just
you can spend the same am a time and get
10 if you just made an effort yeah well
I think a lot of people have that's what
they like I literally spoke to a company
today where they were like what was
working last year isn't working this
year or they're having to put like twice
as much in to get half as much back
totally and it's just like yeah it's
also worth thinking about can you you
know consider what you have been doing
can you be doing that better absolutely
and I think it's quality and quantity
Matrix like I don't believe that it's
one or the other I believe that it can
be both um but it's just about having
some way of monitoring like what is the
quality of the work that we're doing and
how are we how are we monitoring who
we're targeting not just over over email
but like go over the phone and Linkedin
um and then how are making sure that
we're doing enough of it ultimately when
we find something that works so to round
this out then I'm extremely excited to
be doing like just just closely uh
working with you guys this year oh sorry
sorry like really really excited for it
um obviously we're going to have again
we're going to do a number of Live
Events this year y I've heard there's
rumors there's going to be one in
Scotland maybe
yeah make sure everyone's happy with
that but we'll definitely do London
Manchester absolutely OB we we
experimented with Bristol this year
which was fun maybe do a card um
definitely open to Scotland you I think
that'll be we've we've learned we've
really enjoyed these away days that's
what we call them as a as a team um so
yeah I think Scotland's another great
little hub for recruitment companies
definitely um so yeah really excited to
work on more stuff like that obviously
we're going to be uh you know
championing
sourcewell um every single week um which
I'm excited about I think for me the
position that that uh I'm in and and the
podcast and everything I think it's just
so important that you know when we are
partnering companies like yours that you
know there's an actual belief in what
you guys actually do I think that's just
so important so like I was really
excited to try and do something with you
guys just because I just think you know
in terms of thinking about that
workspace and how you can help recruits
I think if if more and more recruiters
get systems in place um and view uh you
know the way that they do their BD the
way that they do their head hunting
candidate um the candidate staff in a
way that you're trying to encourage them
with your product I just think people
will have more and more um success um so
yeah looking forward to highlighting
certain things of the the product this
year I think do you want to just like
would you mind just sharing I guess like
what are the the like if I'm listening
to this right now Y and I've got one or
two of these problems or I'm thinking
about these one or two things what what
are those typically that then means that
they should at least look to understand
how S I might be able to help would you
mind just educating us on that yeah
absolutely sorry there's my wife just
calling me so I'm just uh declining her
call um yeah so I think if you sitting
there right now and you believe that you
need to be booking more meetings with
potential clients or potential
candidates then that's the first that's
the first alarm Bell I think if you're
sitting there saying I I'm booking um
you know and obviously the way to do
that is to be able to assess and analyze
what you're currently doing right I
think if you're sitting there saying
that's that's one thing I need to put
more meetings whether it's clients or
candidates the second one is I feel like
I'm spending so much time just adding
stuff into the CRM system or maybe I'm
not adding anything into the CRM system
and I'm constantly getting it tight from
a manager on a Friday afternoon for for
what I'm doing and and then I think the
third one is like if I feel like I'm
using like multiple different systems
when it comes to Business Development
and head hunting like you know different
ways of Outreach and and I'm managing
across multiple different places and I
just feel that you know coming in every
day and spending an hour trying to think
of who I'm going to reach out to Etc is
is difficult and I think any of those
three things that give me a shout and
you don't have to run a recruitment
business to come and have a conversation
like I'm more than happy to chat to
people um and and talk to them a little
bit more not just about what source
wheel's doing but some of the best
practices that we're just seeing across
the industry in general as well yeah I
love it well I'm excited for the year
ahead excited for you know the work
we're going to do uh with each other so
absolutely looking forward to it thank
you looking forward to as well